سياسيا قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
بلاده لن تزود كيف بمقاتلات اف 16
على سؤال لاحد الصحفيين عما اذا كانت
واشنطن ستزود كيف بالمقاتله
لم تتلقى طلبا من كيف بتسليمها طائرات
مقاتله
مع رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
فان فرنسا لا تستبعد القيام باي شيء
لدعمها ولكن
اهداف ميسي
نحن نقيم الامور في ضوئي ثلاثه شروط الاول
ان يطلب ذلك وان يكون نافع للجيش
الاوكراني وياخذ في الاعتبار التدريب على
الاستخدام واجال التسليم
اي ان المعدات التي نسلمها لا تكون قادره
بطبيعتها على الوساس بالاراضي الروسيه بل
تساعد في الصمود وفي حمايه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والشوط الثالث الا يتسبب الامر
في اضعاف قدراته الفرنسي على حمايه
اراضينا ومواطنيننا في ضوء هذه الشروط كنت
قد قررت بدايه هذا العام تسليما مدرعات
خفيفه وهما سمح بخلق دين ملكيه يرغب فيها
الاوكرانيون وتستجيب لاحتياجاتهم